Now, hopefully you were able to breeze right through
this if you had some slight understanding of these
terms over here. Now, if we compare this first
sequence to the original up here, we see the only
difference is a one letter change right here. That
means that this is going to be a single nucleotide
chain. The second sequence actually looks the same as
the original, except that it's missing a CA right here.
So there's been a deletion. The next one
has actually had an insertion added in for
have been a number two. This fourth one. Notice there was a TAC and then it got
repeated and repeated again. This is what we
call a Trinucleotide repeat. We have three in
a row. And in this last one turned out to be a complete duplication end to end.
The sequence was just duplicated over. So would be number three.